hey francis do you need new investment
ideas no thanks i've got all my cash
tied up in venezuelan crypto ah how is
gringo coin doing it's pronounced
gringot coin my portfolio is now worth a
billion venezuelan bolivars now that's
about three quid then uh
you're right i should have got new
investment ideas well if you want to
take back control of your finances then
fortune and freedom is for you it was
founded by nigel farage who has over 40
years of experience in finance and
politics fortune and freedom is
published by south bank investment
research and is for the investor looking
to access a wide range of informed
opinions on lots of different investing
opportunities their brilliant newsletter
covers everything from causes and the
impact of inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through their daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
fortune and freedom dot com that's
fortune and freedom dot com and sign up
for a free newsletter that will help
your money work for you the link is in
the description
globalization obviously has a bad name
nowadays because of the disruption it's
caused particularly to our countries the
loss of manufacturing jobs all sorts of
other things the fact that suddenly in
the middle of a pandemic we'll realize
we get a lot of our drugs from china and
china may not be sending them quite as
willingly as it has done etc etc but
isn't it fair to say as well that the
period you're describing since the 1950s
through to about 2015 we've all
benefited massively from this process so
the end of globalization is not all good
oh the the end of globalization is going
to be a disaster for most of the world
most of the world cannot feed and fuel
itself without
either direct imports or the inputs
that's necessary to allow them to feed
and fuel themselves from another
continent you break that down you're
talking about food shortages that are
global in scale that affect billions of
people you're talking about an end to
manufactures trade in the way that we
know it which basically strangles tech
in the cradle and you're talking about a
collapse of the ability of energy from
one region to reach another region which
europe is discovering right now means
the lights go out
this these are not positive things it
doesn't mean that there won't be winners
just as in any system there will be
winners and losers
but we've had a lot of winning in the
last 75 years that's about to go away
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today is a
geopolitical analyst whose latest book
is positively titled it's called the end
of the world is just the beginning peter
zahn welcome to trigonometry thank you
very much
uh it's great to have you on the show
man before we get into it and you know
you're a fascinating person to talk to
about uh geopolitics economics and all
of that tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
i've always been interested in how
things work so whether it's geography or
demography or politics or economics i
need to understand how the pieces fit
together which means i absorb
information voraciously and i've worked
in dc for some think tanks i worked for
a private intelligence company and now i
take my
insight and i spell it out for companies
who are trying to figure out what's
coming down the pipe
it means that i'm always absorbing from
everywhere and i get a lot of migraines
and when i go on vacation i have to go
someplace my phone doesn't work so in
21 days i'm going backpacking in
yosemite and i will not come out for a
month
i don't blame you given everything
that's going on and speaking of looking
forward one of the things we wanted to
talk to you about a few months ago was
the conflict uh in ukraine russia's
invasion of ukraine but actually since
then i think a lot of people
particularly people in our audience in
the uk and america are waking up to the
fact that it's very likely that we're
all going to be a lot poorer than we
have been and everybody's sort of
scratching their heads and going why is
that why is that peter
well the world before globalization was
a mosaic tiny little local economies and
if you didn't have what you needed
locally you just did without so if you
didn't have oil you didn't industrialize
if you didn't have food you had a very
small population
and the companies excuse me the
economies the countries that had more
would be able to use that power and
leverage themselves into becoming
empires those empires clashed that
brought us world war ii whole system
collapsed
but uh with globalization in the late
40s and 1950s the americans created a
strategic rubric where the little guy
could actually get by and the little guy
could access
the inputs and the outputs of other
economic systems and so instead of
thousands of tiny little systems we
eventually migrated into a single huge
one
where anyone could import or export
anything to anyone at any time
that gave us global agriculture that
gave us global energy and finance that
gave us global manufacturing supply
chains and ultimately created the world
that we know
but now we're de-globalizing for a mix
of reasons and we're going back in the
direction of thousands of little
disconnected systems which means that
the strength of the whole is now failing
and we're seeing that with ukraine war
and we're seeing that with the chinese
disintegration and we're seeing that
with some of the problems that the
western world is having as they try to
unplug from russia
this is where we're all headed
and peter globalization obviously has a
bad name nowadays because of the
disruption it's caused particularly to
our countries the loss of manufacturing
jobs all sorts of other things the fact
that suddenly in the middle of a
pandemic we realize we get a lot of our
drugs from china and china may not be
sending them quite as willingly as it
has done etc etc but isn't it fair to
say as well that the period you're
describing since the 1950s through to
about 2015 we've all benefited massively
from this process so the end of
globalization is not all good
oh the the end of globalization is going
to be a disaster for most of the world
most of the world cannot feed and fuel
itself without
either direct imports or the inputs
that's necessary to allow them to feed
and fuel themselves from another
continent you break that down you're
talking about food shortages that are
global in scale that affect billions of
people you're talking about an end to
manufacturers trade in the way that we
know it which basically strangles tech
in the cradle and you're talking about a
collapse of the ability of energy from
one region to reach another region which
europe is discovering
right now means the lights go out
this these are not positive things it
doesn't mean that there won't be winners
just in as in any system there will be
winners and losers
but we've had a lot of winning in the
last 75 years that's about to go away
and what are the major reasons peter
behind this d-globe this effect of d
globalization what are the things
contributing to it there are two big
pieces uh first globalization did not
happen on accident
when uh the post-world war ii system was
being born the americans proposed that
we would use our navy the only one to
survive the war
to patrol the global ocean so that
anyone could gauge in any trade with
anyone at any time
this is normally the sort of benefit
that you would have only had if you were
on the winning side of the war and you
were in imperial power already so we
basically made the world open for
everyone and that allowed everyone to
take manufacturing and services jobs and
diversify and specialize and access
anything from a world over
and once that became an option people
started taking those jobs but all of
those jobs are in the cities
and that changed who we are
because in the pre-industrial
pre-globalized world most of us were
farmers and small plot farmers at that
but once we could move into the cities
and take those more value-added jobs it
changed how the way we thought of
families
on the fam on the farm kids are free
labor you have a bunch in the city kids
are really expensive habits you have
very few
you fast forward 75 years and it's not
that we're running out of children that
happened 40 years ago in most of the
world we're now running out of adults
and so we're in a ever accelerating
population crash
so even if
the americans were willing to continue a
20th century strategic policy in a world
where there's no longer a cold war
we no longer have the population
structure for consumption that allows
globalization to work either so whether
it's the front end of the back end this
this period in history is now over and
it's just a question of how we segue
into whatever's next
so i've always been told peter
that we've got too many people the world
is overpopulated that we need to have
less people yet here you are telling me
that actually we don't have enough young
people
the population busts in the advanced
world started in the 1950s and 60s
and that spread to the advanced
developing world in the 1980s to the
2000s with japan i'm sorry with um
with china most aggressively in the
1990s
so it's just that it takes a long time
for for you to realize that a population
i'm sorry a birth rate bust is leading
to a population bust that takes 30 to 50
years well it's now been that in spades
so in the entire advanced world
populations are aging at the same time
they are shrinking and one other thing
when you industrialize for the first
time you don't just get roads and rail
and electricity you also get antibiotics
and medical care so mortality rate
collapses so china's probably the best
example they industrialized starting in
the late 1980s their mortality rate
collapsed their birth rate did not
increase it dropped as well but because
everyone was living longer the
population continued getting bigger
well you play that forward
40 50 years
and now you've got so many people who
are so old they can no longer even have
kids so this this population rubric
belief looks at the core numbers just
sheer numbers and by that
number for the last 40 years yeah the
population's been getting bigger and
bigger and more unsustainable but if you
look under the hood and look at the
younger generation it has been steadily
vanishing now for long enough that we
have run out of people of reproductive
age to generate the next generation in
much of the world china included and so
assuming nothing else goes wrong
assuming globalization holds we're still
looking at a population crash
so we'll probably hit what eight billion
next year will never hit nine and it's
going to be an accelerating fall off
from this point
and that is going to contribute to
deglobalization as you've said what else
is going to happen with this population
crash
uh pick a topic we can go anywhere with
that one uh let's start with the really
unsexy one finance
if
if you're 55 55 60 64 something like
that your kids have moved home your
house has been paid down your incomes
are high your expenses are low you are
the richest you will ever be
and then you move into retirement and
you liquidate all of your investments
and you go into
very rote investments things like
treasury bills and cash because if
there's ever another currency or market
crash you're out of luck you're
destitute
well that is now happening to the baby
boomers this year at the end of this
year that happens in most of the world
and our richest generation ever that is
providing all the financial balance that
has allowed everything to happen is
going to basically take their marbles
and go home
and in most of the world there is not a
generation coming up and behind them the
the gen x generation in the united
states is very small but it's even
smaller relative to the boomers in the
advanced developing world sorry in the
advanced world
so we know that the cost of capital is
going to bear minimum quadruple in the
united states
it will probably increase by a factor of
six to eight in most of the rest of the
world and it won't get better
now in the united states ten years from
now our millennial generation which is a
large generation will enter that
capital-rich demographic but most of the
rest of the world does not have a
millennial generation of size so we're
going to get this split in capital costs
with the americans going one way the
advanced world going another way and
most of the developing world never
having been able to become rich enough
to play their own role so we get to do
all of this
in a period of multi-decade capital
shortages
we don't even have an economic theory
that describes what that is going to
look like
exciting stuff peter
but you know you talk about um the
situation with demographics and you
mentioned
winners and losers
who are going to be the winners of this
situation well the united states is the
first world country in the best position
demographically and in terms of
structurally economically it never
invested its economy into globalization
because it was a bribe we basically
created this environment so that people
would be on our side versus the soviets
so if we had invested our economy in it
we would have just been another empire
and there probably wouldn't have been
all that many takers
so that means the united states can step
away from this system and not suffer too
much pain
france had a very similar view of
globalization because they saw it as an
american strategic play they're like oh
that's what we would have done so of
course they didn't invest their economy
into either the
globalization world or even into the
european union they think of the eu as a
strategic project not an economic one
and so this is they invested into the
european system about the same way that
the brits did
small late have some regrets never went
in whole hog
but then there are countries that can
attach themselves to one of those
systems or maybe start up a little echo
of their own turkey looks pretty good
japan clearly has the military force to
go out and secure the things that it
needs and it has offloaded a lot of
manufacturing base into countries with
better demographic structures
argentina despite its
creative policy making has all the
inputs that it needs to be successful
should it so choose and then other
countries have already managed to kind
of get into the american inner circle
whether that's mexico or canada or
colombia or chile they already have the
legal structure and the trade deals in
place
australia looks good because even though
they're going to suffer a
horrific recession as they adapt to some
of the excesses of the last 30 years
they've got a stable population they've
got resources they've got the raw
materials they've got
an agricultural system that's hugely
export oriented and they're america's
best friends
so you can see countries latching on to
some of the more successful systems and
others trying to go their own way with
various degrees of success
well peter we're sitting here in britain
which i i take it would be on the list
of winners by being sort of under the
umbrella of the u.s is that that is
entirely up to you um one of the
problems that britain has right now is
it still fig hasn't figured out what the
hell it wants to do about brexit i mean
come on guys it's been five years
uh
tell me about it
the smart play would be to go to
washington and ask for a deep free trade
deal and maybe inclusion into nafta
the problem with that strategy is that
we will treat you we have treated you
exactly the same in these talks
as we treated you during lend lease
so we gave you and lend lease 40 odd
outdated badly constructed mothballed
destroyers in exchange for every
military facility you had in the western
hemisphere that's the scale
of the capitulation that washington is
going to demand that means all your
deals with ireland and on northern
ireland have to stick because we like
those that means you have to surrender
to american agricultural norms which
means most of your farms will go out of
business
and that means that the financial hub
needs to move from
london
to new york i mean these are
non-negotiable from the american point
of view and that's one of the reasons
why the trade deal has not happened the
the rhetoric of the brexiteers that they
would just be able to go to washington
and get a better deal not
true
but what the americans are demanding is
the best you are going to get and until
and unless the uk comes to that
conclusion on itself
uh then it is trapped at the edge of the
european system now the european system
is facing its own mortal problems but
you can no longer be part of whatever
the planning is for the next stage
and that does leave you kind of out on
your own and long-range manufacturing
supply chains are no longer viable
anyway so you do need to partner with
someone and that either means going
crawling back to the eu which i don't
think is a viable option anymore
or crawling to washington which is at
best distasteful
right what we're going to be calling is
your point we're sort of on our knees
already to be fair uh but peter one of
the things that uh a lot of what you're
clearly someone with a lot of expertise
a lot of the people who watch our show
uh are not as educated on these issues
but what they're trying to do is
understand what's happening in the world
and what's happening in their lives
right now and we talk a lot about the
cost of living we talk a lot about the
rising price of fuel all of these things
how have government policies played into
this because a lot of people will say
well look the pursuit of net zero
is one of the reasons that all our
prices are going up someone else will
say it's the war in ukraine and people
come up with all of these different
explanations
what do you make of all of that well
let's start with kind of the
conventional wisdom because it's not all
wrong i'm usually the guy who pokes that
but not this time
net zero with today's technology until
we have figured out a low cost mass
storage electricity system and that
means storing electricity not for four
hours but for four months so you can
make it through the winter until we have
that technology net zero is
really dumb from an environmental point
of view forget from an economic point of
view it's suicidal from an economic
point of view but from an environmental
point of view there isn't enough lithium
on the planet to make that work
now in the uk you do have advantages
over almost everyone else in your
hemisphere
because the uk has some of the best wind
resources of the world and if you put a
wind tile or wind turbine high enough
you can tap stronger currents that are
more reliable that can actually generate
base load
we're seeing that in the north sea in
the united states we're seeing that in
texas and we're seeing that in iowa it's
not foolproof but wow is it better than
what we had five or ten years ago so
i don't mean to suggest you can't green
your system i'm just saying that getting
to zero today is not possible
and if you try and if you do it by
decommissioning more reliable energy
producing systems which almost by
default means nuclear or fossil fuel you
are going to have high prices and
rolling brown and blackouts we are
seeing that across central europe right
now the technology just isn't there so
it's real
that doesn't mean you should give up
but peter just to interrupt right if
that's the case then why is everybody
insisting that we do it because it's a
great catchphrase
i mean people have bought the ideology
unfortunately without looking under the
hood we're just not there yet
and europe is now giving us an excellent
example of
40 years of policy of what exactly not
to do
so because it sounds good and it's a
great catchphrase and politicians get to
look all virtuous and moral we embark on
this policy which is fundamentally
unworkable hey hey you guys are the ones
who basically said you wanted a cheese
submarine in the shape of brexit and you
went along with it so this is not an
isolated incident okay
people have ideas
people have bad ideas and politicians of
all flavors strap onto them we've
certainly seen that in my country in the
last five years
you are not unique in that so whether
that makes you feel better or worse i do
not know but i certainly agree that net
zero in its current form with today's
technology
is economically and ecologically
suicidal
uh but that's only one piece so okay
we've got the ukraine war then uh the
russians have recently shut off
nordstream and we know that all the
pipelines that are crossing ukraine to
europe are going to get blown up one way
or another this calendar year so you can
count on
roughly
five or four to six million barrels a
day of crude and
roughly
uh oh geez i gotta translate this one
sorry i'm thinking bcf
it's 9 to 12 bcf so what's that 90 to
120 million billion cubic meters of um
natural gas a year going offline before
the end of the year and that will
obviously sucker punch everyone in
europe repeatedly again uk has a little
bit different system you're further from
the russians you hardly use any of their
stuff you have the option of taking
stuff from the north sea first you have
closer access to lng from the united
states so you're going to be able to
watch europe and when you're not
giggling because that would be rude
you're hopefully going to learn a few
things on not what on what not to do as
you're adjusting your own energy plans
but all of that is going to be
inflationary no matter who you are
we're losing potash fertilizer that used
to come from russian belarus we're
losing phosphate fertilizer which used
to come from china
and we are losing nitrogen fertilizer
which is made from natural gas
globally so we know food prices have to
go up again i don't see the uk starving
but that contributes to inflation
but what's really going on in my opinion
is a labor story
in the uk in the us our largest
generation has been our baby boomers
they're all retiring right now
and the kids who are 0 to 20 who are now
moving into the workforce they are the
lowest the smallest generation that
either of our countries has ever seen
in the united states that is already an
annual shortage of 400 000 workers in my
country that's going to go up for the
next 12 years until we hit 900 000
so we are looking at labor inflation
here
being higher
than inflation in energy and food and
manufactured goods combined
for a decade
so peter again that being the case um
how come politicians haven't looked at
this and thought right there is a
problem coming down the pipe let's give
people incentives let's give people
incentives to produce kids let's make it
better for families and make it more
sustainable and less expensive
that's a lot more difficult than it
sounds now the advantage we've had in
the united states is we've got the elbow
room we're the world's largest producer
and exporter of food we're the world's
largest producer of energy products and
we have more arable land per person than
any other country in the world and that
has kept the costs for all of the inputs
for families low without a government
policy
the uk has is lower productivity and
agriculture its energy reserves aren't
tapped out but they're well past their
peak and most of you live in a
relatively dense urban environment
that's just by nature is going to be
more expensive
so if you do decide you want to fix this
with policy the country to have a
conversation with sweden
and not so much about what to do
but about what not to do
sweden has maintained a higher birth
rate than most countries certainly most
countries in europe and they do have a
cradle to grave social security social
support network
but it's come with some of the highest
tax rates in the world which actually
makes sweden a very expensive place to
live it wasn't for the the support no
one would be able to have a family in
addition there are a lot of societal
negatives that come from it so for
example uh
they've got this great program where a
young mother with her first kid has gets
so many months
off work that with pay if she has a
second kid it adds on an additional time
plus some same for a third step or
fourth
what that means is if you're under age
35 in sweden and you're a woman it's
impossible to get hired
because you could go in for your first
day of work say you're pregnant and then
not work a day for eight years
so yes higher birth rate but it comes at
the cost of just screaming economic
inequality between the sexes
this is hard social engineering is
incredibly difficult it will always
have side effects
the united states has been fortunate in
that geography takes care of most of it
for us
very interesting that is very very
interesting peter because you would
think that
somebody must have been able to crack
this puzzle by now because as you've
explained and we're starting to see now
the labor shortages are having a huge
effect we're going to be you know well
by the time this comes out we would have
we would have flown to the us and
there's part of me thinking are we
actually going to be able to make the
flights no we're going to make it the
suitcase not so much
because i've got two in the wind right
now i feel your pain
because it seems every industry
is crippled by these shortages
and they're not going away i mean the
baby boomers the largest generation the
west has ever had and they're going away
and they are never coming back in the
united states we have to wait 10 years
for the millennials to kind of fill this
out
most of the advanced world doesn't have
a millennial generation
so we're not going back to where we were
pre-covered or pre-trump that is not
possible we don't have the numbers we
have to find a new way to function
and if you want to get a little
optimistic slash depressed it all
depends upon your point of view if i'm
going to get out there
yeah if i'm right about china and we're
looking at the disintegration of the
chinese system and if i'm right about
germany and we're looking at the end of
the german system this year
that's a lot of manufacturing that go is
going away
now your country and my country are
excellent at manufacturing in terms of
value added we're actually better than
the germans
but
to rebuild those supply chains somewhere
else especially in short order
especially during a time of protracted
labor shortages
that is also inflationary
and peter there's always been the
traditional solution certainly in this
country in recent years which is
well yeah we've got labor shortages but
what we're going to do is we're going to
get a bunch of people we're going to
cream off the best people from bulgaria
and romania and poland and maybe ukraine
now and and also from north africa and
maybe sub-saharan and we'll just get a
bunch of people in from everywhere and
solve the labor shortage isn't that the
way
uh by the numbers that has a possibility
of working now in the european union
that is exactly what you did for the
last 15 years and it's one of the
reasons why the central european
economies are now facing demographic
collapse everyone who's under 30 left
for the west
or the western european countries you
can only do that once
so you're talking about now going
further afield
in that the united kingdom absolutely
has an advantage over the rest of the eu
because the uk has always had a more
open definition of self because by by
definition the uk is a merger of
multiple ethnicities without necessarily
erasing them in the way that the french
did or the germans did and that makes
you a little bit more culturally open
but it will not happen by accident
you're a freaking island and you just
need to build the system that allows
them to come in either from the former
colonies or from countries that are
closer there are ways to skin that cat
all of them generate a degree of
political backlash and i think it's safe
to say that everyone in the uk right now
has a fresh appreciation for just how
touchy you can be when it comes to your
politics
in the united states we learned that
lesson five years ago with donald trump
and for people who thought that all it
was going to take was the fall of trump
and the rise of mind to change it no
our immigration policy is if anything
tighter than now than it was two years
ago
this requires a significant cultural
adaptation we go through phases and
right now
both countries
kind of like the doors shut
and peter you mentioned something about
german about the german system
collapsing now i haven't heard anything
about this
but it does sound exciting yeah it does
you know he's got a jewish background so
he's thrilled but
[Laughter]
sure i'm glad he laughed at that
otherwise that joke is very problematic
but anyway peter
it's like there is no longer anything
but bad humor in my life
[Laughter]
okay so the um
the german system has four pillars of
support and without all four
it doesn't work number one inexpensive
energy supplies from
russia it's the only place that the
germans can get the stuff cheap and it
forms the basis of their heavy industry
which provides the materials for their
medium and their light industries so if
something happens that in the base level
it's not just that they have a problem
with electricity although they do it's
that they no longer have the materials
that's necessary to make plastics or to
forge steel or to do anything downstream
of that
the nordstream pipeline went offline
yesterday there's a concern a very real
concern that it's never going to come
back on what's going on right now is
that the russians are trying to
blackmail the germans into backing out
of nato it's that simple because without
german assistance
there are no logistical means of getting
equipment from the rest of nato into
ukraine end of story so the germans are
being forced to decide between being
industrialized and neutral
or unindustrialized and western
not a fun conversation
the germans are the fastest aging
society in europe they're in the top
five globally
germany is not a country where you can
have an open honest national
conversation about population policy and
it shows and so they now have more
people in their 60s than their 50s than
their 40s than their 30s than their 20s
until now this has worked because when
you have a lot of people in your 40s 50s
and early 60s without kids they can work
long they can work hard they can get
better educated they're the most
productive workers on the planet
but
that group that is in the 60s is now
flipping into retirement this decade and
that changes things overnight going from
an advanced worker base with lots of
experience to a retired worker base
where the experience is irrelevant that
happens this decade that was always
going to happen this decade this was
always going to be the last decade of
the german manufacturing model
third
it's not just about the germans a
successful manufacturing system
requires different stages of production
with different workforces with different
skill sets at different costs
the americans do this with mexico the
germans do this with poland and the
czech republic and romania
and ukraine
and it's now over
and then finally you need globalization
because when you have an advanced
population that's top-heavy you don't
have enough people to consume
you have to export the stuff
and the americans have lost interest
so it's not just nordstrom that's just
the proximate cause of the day
all four of these pillars were already
breaking
the demographic ones were definitely
going to break completely this decade
with the americans it all depends upon
our mood
and then of course the russians are just
forcing things into the light right now
so the german manufacturing model cannot
survive the 2020s
the russians get to decide whether it
survives 2022.
wow and so obviously that in the german
economy economy is such a powerhouse if
that goes down then that is going to
have
shockwaves right across europe it takes
belgium and poland and the netherlands
and all of the central european
economies down with it and the french
are left to inherit the earth that's a
depressing thought there we go
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows of course but
only if it's check of play about
collapse of russian aristocracy as they
face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
peter
i wanted to talk about china because
this is another area where you have very
uh you have ideas that are very
different to most people a lot of people
including former guest of ours we had dr
john lee on the show recently talking
about
what china is trying to do the threat of
china and vis-a-vis taiwan etc
you believe that again due to
demographic issues particularly and also
this end of globalization china is on
the verge of collapse tell us about that
well let's deal with the punchline first
china doesn't survive the decade as an
industrial power uh probably not even as
a unified country
the demographic situation now there is
so bad that and the aging is happening
so quickly and the birth rate dropped so
low so long ago
that uh by 2050 the population of china
will be less than half of what it is
today
and we're already in a situation in
i'm going to i was going to phrase that
wrong well remember germany has more in
their 60s and 50s and the 40s and so on
their demographic does this towards the
children
china's does this
right their point of no return was 30
years ago
this is not a recent thing combination
of the fastest urbanization humanities
ever experienced with the one child
policy at the same time that was
national suicide and now they're dying
they no longer have a workforce that is
competitive in any manufacturing sector
there is not a product that is made
anywhere else in the world that i'm
sorry there's not a product made in
china it can't be made cheaper elsewhere
and the only reason we still think of
china as a manufacturing power at all
is because of the pre-existing sunk cost
of the industrial plant but the kovid
lockdowns are even removing that from
the table so there's no reason to expect
china to ever get better
also their energy comes from a continent
away except for the part that comes from
two continents away
also all of the inputs that they need
for the food with the exception of
phosphate fertilizer they're all
imported so anything happens to
globalization for any reason and this is
a chinese this is a country that just
ceases to exist there is no way
with deglobalization that china emerges
from this decade with less i'm sorry
with more than 700 million people it's
going to be that bad and that
catastrophic
well that does sound uh obviously hugely
impactful in china but does that mean
would you say that that means china is
not a threat because you know i'm
originally from russia uh and people
have been banging on about the
demographic death spiral of russia since
i was i was a child and yet here is
russia invading uh ukraine and upsetting
the global balance of power and causing
all of these problems that we're now
talking about
should is it really the case that we
shouldn't worry about what the chinese
are going to do
it's a fun little compare and contrast
so
the russian demographic is awful it will
lead to a dissolution of the russian
state this century probably around
mid-century if i was a betting man
but
it's not so rapid because russia when it
urbanized it only urbanized in part and
when it industrialized it only
industrialized in part so until you get
to the post-soviet collapse the
demographics really i mean they were
ugly by many measures but they weren't
terminal
and there are some strategic things that
the russians can do to buy themselves
more time the ukraine war is part of
that
they're trying to get to a more
defensible outer shell where they can
put static forces in a few geographic
areas that will block forces from coming
into their space in the future
so i don't mean to suggest that the
russian situation is pretty it is still
terminal
but there are some things that you can
do with strategic policy that buy more
time
china doesn't have that option
russia is an exporter of food and energy
china's an importer russia can plug its
periphery china's periphery is naval
there is no country or combination of
countries that the chinese can invade
and conquer in order to solve any of
their problems where there's a nice list
for the russians
so the most likely outcome here is that
china just kind of implodes into itself
does that mean there can't be a war of
course not when countries are dying you
never know what they're going to do
the the issue of the moment of course
seems to be taiwan
but the chinese government now knows
that if they make a move on taiwan it's
a going to be harder than they thought
b they know they're going to be
international sanctions
and c they know they're going to be
international boycotts and any one of
those is enough to destroy the chinese
system much less all three at once
the chinese have always thought of
russia as their dumb neighbor and you
let the dumb neighbor try things the
canary in the coal mine if you will
and they now know that everything
they've prepared for for the last 40
years
was based on faulty assumptions
this is normally
the place where you would as a national
leader send all of your smart people
into another room to kind of game out
some replacement plantings
but the cult of personality in china is
now so tight and she has executed so
many people at the top that he no longer
has a brain trust to send into the other
room
so china's just slamming its head into
the wall over and over and over and over
until something cracks and i don't think
that's something that's going to be
taiwan
well peter you mentioned
the reason that you think russia is
doing what it's doing in ukraine which
is to secure
a more defensible position you mentioned
that there are other places where it
needs to plug those gaps as well
what does the conflict uh and the future
of russian aggressive behavior in
eastern europe look like in your opinion
when the russians did that first thunder
run to kharkiv and kiev and they
realized that they were not going to be
welcomed into saviors that no one had
bought their propaganda but themselves
they had to
reassess
ukraine the problem with ukraine from
the russian point of view is not that
it's in one of those geographic gaps
it's that it's on the way to two of them
so it's not that the russians aren't
going to stop until they have all
ukraine it's that they won't stop when
they have all of ukraine
and that meant they had to dust off an
older
playbook and that's why we're seeing
another artillery now they're
deliberately destroying every piece of
civilian infrastructure they can see
specifically agricultural infrastructure
to make sure that the land is
uninhabitable for at least several years
because that forces the population to
self-segregate either into
refugees which leave and you don't have
to worry about them
or anyone who just stays is clearly a
fighter and you can set the wagner group
or the chechens on them just to wipe
them out and that's what we've seen in
southern ukraine and eastern ukraine for
the most part and we're seeing these
incremental gains by artillery
if the russians succeed that doesn't
simply
destroy
the ukrainian nation and the ukrainian
state
it's just the next step
in getting to those gaps and that means
estonia latvia lithuania poland
excuse me moldova and romania have to
fall as well
on the western periphery of the russian
space those are the countries that the
russians feel they have to have to have
to hold
and if they pull that off then the fsb
is released to do what the fsb was
designed to do and that's to suppress
all national dissent no matter what the
form everywhere it goes
from the russian point of view that's
the easy part the hard part is
conquering the country in the first
place
well peter sorry francis let's just
finish off on this uh as as someone
who's less of an expert in the economic
side of this uh but someone who is from
russia who's been paying attention i've
been saying this to people for a long
time like this is just the beginning
it's part of a much bigger plan
but i suppose that the the most valid
counter argument to that would be would
it not be suicide for russia to attack
nato countries like latvia estonia
lithuania romania etc
well
we found out in the first week of the
war that the russians military from a
conventional point of view was not
nearly as important as it looked to be
we now know that the united states nato
in general is running out of a lot of
the equipment that the ukrainians need
to fight because that's not how our
militaries are designed the us does not
do mass formations we do precision from
distance to destroy command and control
and logistic hubs and then we go in and
clean up the russians are going inch by
inch by inch destroying everything
and fighting that requires a different
sort of military and we can't train
ukraine with the weapons that we use for
the long-range stuff because that isn't
something you do in a few weeks that's
something that takes a few years we
don't have that kind of time even if we
were willing to share our top shelf
technology which i think is uh
open to debate
so we're running out
of the sort of stuff that the ukrainians
can use and we're probably going to be
largely tapped by october
so if ukraine has not ripped the guts
out of the russian military by then
this war is going to take a very
different term because you will have a
large manpower heavy russian army that
is has low morale and poor equipment
against a
ukrainian force that doesn't have
weapons
there's no math there
but the russians know they can't face us
in a conventional war
and that's where the nukes come into
play
especially especially especially if the
germans have flipped because if the
germans have flipped there's no defense
of estonia latvia lithuania poland and
romania
anyway
so the russians are playing their cards
on the diplomatic and the economic side
of this very very well and to be
perfectly blunt it's not a hard hand to
play
the germans have
pushed for 40 years
against depending upon russian energy
and raw materials and we're seeing where
it leads and before you criticize the
germans overlay because you know that's
that's justified
this is not a new problem
germany and russia are our neighbors
and they try to get along so that they
don't have to go to war and then it
ultimately falls apart and they go to
war and they go try to get it again
afterwards to try to prevent the next
one that's all they can do it's just
that we're unlucky enough to be living
in a time where we're in one of the the
ziggs rather than the zags
peter
the the the paint the picture you're
painting
is is very bleak it's very bleak it's
very bleak
with everything really but you describe
yourself as an optimist so what is it to
be optimistic about well history is a
series of cycles of an organizational
structure forming and generating a
golden age and then breaking apart under
its own inconsistencies and collapsing
and what we know is history is highs and
lows highs and lows
globalization has been the biggest high
we have ever had
and its break apart was always going to
hurt
a lot the demographics are just
faltering in on top of that making it
worse
but
we're now in a position where roughly
half of the earth's surface has
industrialized and urbanized and is not
subject to the collapse will it be
inflation yeah
will it be awkward yeah but think of the
level of awkwardness that the uk and the
u.s has to do we have to double the size
of our industrial plan yeah that's
expensive yeah that's inflationary
that's a wonderful opportunity it's
going to generate some of the fastest
growth in human history in the next five
to 10 years
we know that global agricultural supply
chains are going away
but not ones in north america or in the
uk most likely which means we can
incorporate some of the digital
technologies that are past the prototype
stage into the next generation of farm
equipment and double yield this is a
good thing it's inflationary in the
short term but it's a good thing
unlike the great collapses of the past
large portions of the world large viable
portions of the world are not breaking
so when we get to our next rise 20 30
years from now
all of the building blocks of society of
today will not have been lost this is
not the bronze stage collapse this is
not the fall of rome this isn't even the
disintegration in the aftermath of world
war ii
there's pain
there's going to be a lot of ugly
but we're not looking at a
civilizational break here like we have
every
other
time
that's a good thing
it's so interesting that you say that
because we talk to people
and a lot of commentators not very
intelligent people journalists political
thinkers they they make the point that
what we're seeing are the final days of
rome and you don't think that i think
we're seeing imagine if we could see the
final days of the roman system without
the final days of rome some version of
that is where we're going
this is not like some
this isn't like the dark ages where the
arabs held the knowledge but didn't
touch it for a thousand years
silicon valley's still there london is
still there and it's going to keep being
silicon valley in london
what's happening is a contraction of
what we consider to be the economic
family of the world and the parts of the
world that are more viable
and we're going to be able to continue
to tinker with these technologies until
the rest of the world is ready to rejoin
that could be a lot worse
and peter in terms of some of the other
things that are going on obviously you
focus on the economics the demographics
the geography etc uh how does um
the sort of modern informational
landscape landscape play into this
because the reason i ask this is you
often when i hear you speaking i'm sort
of hearing a lot of rationality
and i know and as you've mentioned
earlier that not all our decisions in
politics and in in the world in general
are made by rational actors in
responding to
a rational observation of the facts and
and the and the data
so we now live in a world where there's
an abundance of information we're all
connected by
ways of communicating didn't exist
before how does that affect the
landscape and the way that our politics
will develop over time well social media
is definitely part of the problem rather
than part of the solution because we've
given every yahoo a bullhorn
and those yahoos sometimes get together
say the same thing and elect people to
congress and parliament
there's not a lot we can do about that
at the moment but i think a bit of a
historical comparison it might be useful
in the 1800s we had a new technology
called the telegraph which like social
media today revolutionized our
relationship between geography and
information suddenly you could send
information across a continent in
seconds
and that generated yellow journalism
because like with social media today
there were no restrictions on who could
share the information and so people
would just make stuff up
and among other things that got the
united states involved in the
spanish-american war
because people eventually bought the
propaganda well it wasn't propaganda it
was just flat out lies and that
triggered a conflict that also among
other things is shaping our political
space in both of our countries right now
we're seeing that with trump we're
seeing that with johnson we're seeing
that with everyone who wants to
challenge them
now
social media
will eventually be brought into check
just like the telegraph did eventually
we both passed slander and label laws
we need something like that for social
media
do we do that in a year
probably not
if so the americans would have done it
in the aftermath of the january 6th
issue
of uh of last year or i said already the
year before sorry time is flying by
uh but that is an issue for my congress
and for your parliament
i would expect
parliament to act on it quicker because
your system is less clunky than ours
it's actually designed to government
it's designed to govern as opposed to
designed to debate
so
we are in the us once again looking to
our parents
for a potential path out of this
please don't let us down
well we we will do our best peter we'll
do our best isn't part of the problem
though peter is that no one we haven't
nobody has really got to grips with this
technology no with and it's
it's new i mean remember social media
was only designed what 15 years ago and
only kind of entered into the mass
consciousness within the last six it's
very very
new
and one of the many reasons i'm looking
to the uk rather than the us for the
first steps on this
you guys don't have a constitution
normally that's a negative we're seeing
that with brexit but it means little
things like free speech are not inviable
and that allows you to tinker with the
legal structure that's necessary to
contain this technology without
immediately threatening the core
precepts of your country this is a good
thing because it allows you flexibility
that we don't have
well it does unfortunately the people in
charge instead of trying to find a
sophisticated solution to regulate
social media instead they're getting the
police to investigate comedians for
jokes they tell and asking people to
check their thinking and all of this
other knowledge that is one of the
downsides of your system i will give you
that there there's no chance there not
having it all written down sometimes as
a negative one usually is not the not
for this now something else that's
different about our systems another
reason i'm looking to the uk over the us
on this
when your leader
does something
monumentally stupid
even legal
you can get rid of them in a day because
you can go through the party as well as
through parliament we don't have that
option we're in locked term limits so if
johnson was our president today we would
have to wait a minimum of two and a half
years to ditch him
you guys did it in an afternoon
speed matters right now
and peter
there's going to be a lot of people
listening to this and what you've
painted is a very persuasive yet bleak
image of the world and
and its future
if you're an ordinary person who's
listening to this what advice would you
give them what would you say to them in
order to help negotiate what is coming
down the pipe
uh you need to understand where the
things that make your life possible come
from
if it's a secure system you're good if
it's not a secure system you need to
personally invest in other means of
sourcing otherwise when those things go
off you'll just be doing without
there's it's it's not a simple process
supply chains are messy but anything
that ultimately links back to the
chinese or the russian system in
particular
you know that's going away you know
that's going away very very soon and so
best to be
forthright with what the nature of your
problem is so you can actually start
solving it before it explodes in your
face
germany is a textbook case of what
happens when you do the opposite
well there we go so if you're reading
watching this rather than your ordinary
person start manufacturing everything
that you've been buying for every china
everything
great fantastic peter well you've given
us some pointers there uh before we let
you go uh the last question we always
ask uh before we ask questions from our
supporters for our supporters of course
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be i think of all the
economic sectors that are facing
upheaval the one that people are really
under
estimating is agriculture we've got a
global disruption to the entire
fertilizer supply chain right now and
building new fertilizer capacity is a
minimum of a three year investment
roughly eighty percent of the calories
we grow
is grown with imported inputs and we're
going to have a really good idea by
september october of this year of just
how bad on a global scale the harvest is
going to be
it will not improve until such time as
we have rebuilt that fertilizer capacity
and that's you're talking 20 20 20 20 25
at the soonest
uh
we're not ready for that none of us are
ready for that
all right pizza so listen uh thanks for
coming on the show what i will say is
this you've made a lot of predictions i
hope you're wrong about all of them uh
however
however uh if if you're not we'd love to
have you back on the show in in like a
year or so so you can say i told you so
that's why you don't have electricity
anymore that's not why i do this and if
you don't have electricity they're not
going to be watching
yes
i know i know but but anyway my point is
we appreciate your time we appreciate
your expertise uh and uh we hope you're
wrong about everything but if you're not
let's do this again sometime it sounds
great
the book is called uh the end of the
world is just the beginning uh and there
it is uh if you if you were not enthused
and inspired and motivated enough by
this interview make sure you get the
book as well peter we're gonna ask you a
couple of questions from our supporters
for our locals but for now thank you for
coming on the show and thank you guys
for watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another uplifting episode
just like this one
and for those of you who like yeah it
has been fun for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
[Music]
how does peter see the almost total
worldwide control by certain countries
of certain key minerals like antimony
and lithium playing out in the next few
years
[Music]
you